si paris cette saison avec lionel messi
remporte la ligue des champions et du
symbolisme en terme de timing ce sera
absolument parfait et ils veulent une
fanfare un peu aussi pour la coupe du
monde 2022 qui est la priorité de
l'émirat pourquoi le qatar utilise le
sport le foot plus particulièrement
comme outil de soft power i si vous
regardez en termes d'argent le fou ce
qu'on dit c'est de l'argent si c'est que
dalle en fait c'est peanuts donc si vous
voulez aujourd'hui être affiché à
travers tous les continents avoir une
image et en plus un an de la coupe du
monde c'est rêver pour le qatar parce
qu'on va reparler d'eux et encore pour
des raisons d'ailleurs plutôt mélioratif
plutôt bien fait
[Musique]
la violence peut déstabiliser la société
pro de sécurité de mettre en danger nos
libertés
[Musique]
si la dette on parle de 150 mille
enfants donc amérindiens métis et inuits
qui ont été envoyés dans ces pensionnats
comment ça s'est passé le début de cette
politique
coloniale était de venir en territoire
et prendre enfin sans le consentement
des parents et ils arachides leur
territoire pour les amis dans d'autres
régions dans deux provinces très très
loin l'objectif est de tuer il a été
dans un singe en justement 182 tombes
anonymes ont été découvertes sur le site
d'un ancien pensionnat à cranbrook en
colombie britannique
et c'est la troisième découverte de ce
type en un mois on parle ici de génocide
et de politique génocidaire ça va au
delà de la culture mais plutôt un crime
contre
l'humanité observe une nation
ep
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque jour du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce lundi 13 septembre à sept
mois de l'élection présidentielle en
france la liste des candidats officiels
se précise ce week-end anne hidalgo la
maire ps de paris s'est lancé dans la
course candidature également confirmé
pour marine le pen au rassemblement
national le parti communiste français et
fait lui son grand retour après quinze
années d'absence à la présidentielle
avec fabien roussel alors quel programme
pour ces candidats arriveront ils à
mobiliser les français décryptage dans
un instant avec nos invités
un combat de boxe pour faire son retour
politique c'est le choix très
métaphorique est fait à donald trump
pour revenir sur la scène publique le 11
septembre l'ancien président américain
qui s'est desserré aux critiques sur la
gestion politique du président actuel
joe biden lui reprochant notamment
d'avoir retiré trop tôt les troupes
américaines d'afghanistan
ses partisans ont signé voulu retenir
une allusion sur ses ambitions pour 2024
et puis à 21h place à notre désormais
incontournable rendez-vous qu'en pensent
les français nous sommes allés ce soir
la rencontre de clara bouaziz elle a
perdu son père au tout début de la
pandémie elle fait partie de ces plus de
14 mille 500 plaignants qui ont déposé
plainte auprès de la cour de justice de
la république
plusieurs ministres ou anciens membres
du gouvernement sont visées pour leur
gestion de la pandémie
mais avant de se pencher sur la
présidentielle en france avec nos
invités on s'intéresse à la ferme pénale
a devant la justice depuis ce matin
l'ancien collaborateur d'emmanuel macro
est jugé pour plusieurs va faire un
procès étalés sur trois semaines que je
suis pour nous notre reporter monaco dès
lors bonsoir mona alexandre bédat qui
comparaît donc notamment pour avoir
brutalisé un couple lors des
manifestations du 1er mai 2018 mais pas
seulement
oui alors beaucoup de sujets ont été
abordés vous l'imaginez stéphanie lors
de cette première grande audience pour
alexandre benalla la présidente du
tribunal correctionnel isabelle
prévost-desprez a commencé d'abord par
la lecture du rapport ainsi que tous les
sujets qui seront abordés tout au long
de ce procès alexandre reynal a ensuite
été convié à la barre la présidente a
épluché chaque ligne de son cv de son
parcours professionnel est la voix posée
plutôt bavard alexandre benalla a décrit
sa fiche de poste alors qu'il était à
l'elysée il raconte notamment avoir
voulu rejoindre la république en marche
en septembre 2016 plutôt pour l'
aventure humaine que pour le côté
financier il dit je cite mon poste c'est
est de régler les problèmes mais ça
s'appelle directeur de la sécurité et de
la sûreté
et mona la présidente a abordé ensuite
la disparition du mystérieux coffre fort
au domicile d'alexandre mais dallas
exactement stéphanie il explique l'avoir
dissimulé car son adresse était devenu
public qu'il voulait éviter l'intrusion
de personnes mal intentionnées à son
domicile selon lui il n'avait jamais été
question de dissimuler la vérité son
avocate est ensuite intervenue pour
expliquer que la sphère du fameux coffre
fort et est toujours en cours ensuite
concernant le port d'armes hors cadre
professionnel c'est là que la situation
s'est légèrement tendu lors de cette
audience alexander benn a expliqué qu'il
se sentait exposés au danger dans sa vie
personnelle et qu'il devait se protéger
en portant une arme il s'est donc
comparé aux policiers de magnanville qui
ont été tués et c'est là que les
explications n'ont pas convaincu la
présidente qui l'a arrêté tout de suite
et qui lui a dit je cite là c'est un
petit peu limite monsieur ben ali et
mona la présidente est ensuite revenu
sur le fameux selphy de 2017 ou
alexandre men à la tient une arme
moi je vous le disais stéphanie de
différents sujets ont été abordés
aujourd'hui c'était un petit peu le
moment cocasse de ce procès puisque le
cmfi a été projeté en salle d'audience
où les yeux à des journalistes de ces
parties civiles de la défense ce dernier
assure que cette arme est un glock
factice et que la photo est certes
idiote et inappropriée et des
déclarations qui n'ont vraisemblablement
pas convaincu est la présidente cette
audience elle s'est terminée aux
alentours de 19h30 elle reprendra dès
demain vous l'avez compris ce procès et
bien ils risquent d'être haut en
couleurs alexandre benalla va
comparaître jusqu'au 1er octobre soit
sept mois avant le premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle on suivra avec
vous merci monaco dès lors en direct
donc du tribunal correctionnel de paris
et la ferme et nana qui est à l'origine
on s'en souvient du premier séisme qui a
ébranlé le quinquennat macron un procès
qui se tient à sept mois du premier tour
de la présidentielle pour l'instant le
chef de l'état n'est pas encore
officiellement lancée dans la course à
sa réélection mais ses nombreux
déplacements on dise beaucoup
boudou trop politiques ont dès ce
week-end annoncé eux clairement leurs
intentions anne hidalgo la maire ps de
paris officialisé sa candidature depuis
rouen hier la présidente du fn marine le
pen a elle confirmé ses ambitions hier
depuis fréjus dans le var et puis après
15 ans d'absence le parti communiste
français annoncée lors de la fête de
l'huma la candidature du député du nord
fabien roussel au total donc ce sont
treize candidats officiellement déclarés
d'autres sont évidemment probable bref
le paysage politique se dessine plus en
plus de plus en plus nettement c'est
l'objet de notre décryptage ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec cyril
martinez référent national au numérique
chez les patriots en direct avec nous
bonsoir céline martinez sur ce plateau
maxime thibeault docteur en droit public
bonsoir maxime thibeault et alexis à
poulain que l'on connaît bien ici
puisque c'est notre haine et de relais
pardon j'en perds mes mots éditorial srt
bonsoir alexis merci d'être avec nous
vous avez failli me pète avec les
bouchons c'est pas rien voilà c'est
paris 30 km quand on est on est ravi que
nous soyons arrivés à temps alors
direction fréjus 1 pour commencer où
marine le pen a transmis les rênes du
parti ce week-end à jordan bardella elle
est devenue très officiellement la
candidate du rassemblement national à la
présidentielle 2022 écouter
en 2022 cette élection présidentielle ne
sera pas seulement un choix de société
comme en plus d'être léger précédent
scrutin ce sera un choix de civilisation
un choix de vie et d'avenir pour nos
enfants un choix de sécurité et de
puissance pour notre pays un soir de
liberté et d'indépendance
en avril 2022 ce sera davantage qu'un
vote
un choix historique
alors au moins c'est clair vous pensez
maxime thibeault que c'est également ce
que dit marine le pen un choix
historique 2022 je pense que les années
passant il faut faire un moment le choix
de la france ou bien de la région france
au sein de l'union européenne aux siens
au sein d'un système mondialisé qui
malheureusement fait que notre pays avec
son indépendance et sa souveraineté
disparaît progressivement alors vous
allez marine le pen qui soutient le fait
la france doit redevenir une nation vous
avez arnaud montebourg vous avez florian
philippot à monsieur dupont-aignan donc
vous avez quand même du monde mais c'est
sûr que cette élection de 2022 va être
primordiale pour déterminer l'avenir du
pays et il est plus qu urgent d'avoir
une solution plutôt nationale à mon sens
qu'une solution européenne mondialistes
parce que ma envoie derrière toutes les
conséquences au plan industriel son plan
économique pour le pays
même diagnostic avec six poulains 2022
sera sera un choix historique à un
tournant dans les présidentielles ça
dépend vraiment des programmes et des
candidats parce que comme on a cinquante
nuances de vert chez les écologistes on
a un peu 50 nuance de souverainisme chez
les candidates déclarées un
souverainiste en réalité il faut les
moyens de cette souveraineté retrouvée
je ne sais pas si on les a si on peut
les avoir en cinq ans ça me paraît court
et puis tous ont toujours un rapport
assez ambiguë avec l'union européenne
personne ne parle réellement de phr
excite ni dans des coûts c'était le cas
de marine le pen à l'élection précédente
elle a totalement changé aujourd'hui il
est question de revoir un peu les
traités de penser que le droit français
c'est supérieur au droit européen et le
traité c'est loin d'être le cas donc
cette question là oui évidemment elle va
être importante pour l'échéance 2022
mais attention encore une fois il ya
beaucoup de nuances et beaucoup de
promesses c'est une élection
présidentielle la réalité d'une
souveraineté retrouvée pour la france
c'est encore autre chose céline martinez
vu le succès des manifestations
organisées
ce week-end par notamment les patriotes
1 le parti de florian philippot est ce
que marine le pen pourrait renouer
justement avec son ancien comparse où
vous ferez vraiment cavalier seul dans
cette élection alors vous me posez une
question qui est assez basse je ne peux
pas parler au nom de florian philippot
mais à ma connaissance ou et est la
meilleure stratégie pour votre parti
alors je vous la pose différemment nous
c'est de rester clair droit dans nos
idées marine le pen enfin vraiment que
j'ai l'impression d'entendre le disque
oreiller depuis plusieurs années elle
parle de choix historique de liberté et
c'est tout en rognant tout ce qui à tout
ce qui relève de justement de la liberté
l'union européenne les questions de
l'otan
enfin voilà il ya quelque chose qui
tourne pas rond il ya une incohérence
totale avec marine le pen est donc enfin
je pense que les patriotes eux n'ont
rien à faire avec un mouvement qui à
renier tout ce qui faisait sa
souveraineté tout ce qu'ils défendent
est en réalité les questions de
souveraineté française voilà et puis
alexis pu analyser ya pas deux il n'y a
pas de réel candidat qui se prononcent
pour le président si florian philippot
et françois asselineau sont deux
candidats clair à dire un gouffre exit
voilà
juste pour corriger les attaques alors
l'autre fabre qui a lancé sa candidature
ce week-end on l'a dire d'introduction
c'est évidemment anne hidalgo la maire
de paris qui s'est délocalisé pour
l'occasion de se lancer dans la course 2
à l'elysée depuis le bord de seine à
rouen et côté
aujourd'hui je suis prête
j'ai décidé d'être candidate à la
présidence de la république française
cher française et chers français je veux
que tous les enfants de france aient la
même chance que celle qui m'a été donnée
je suis candidate pour offrir un avenir
à nos enfants à tous nos enfants
je veux avec vous tout faire pour
réparer pour retrouver le goût du
dialogue et du débat pour bâtir une
france plus juste plus forte une france
plus sûre dont la voix singulière doit à
nouveau porté en europe et dans le monde
maxime thibeault a changé d'avis
puisqu'il ya moins d'un an elle
promettait anne hidalgo de ne pas y
aller un qu'elle ne ferait pas campagne
que pensez vous de cette candidature
elle a l'air plutôt de de faire certains
émus en tout cas à gauche à son crédit
on dirait qu'il n'ya que les imbéciles
qui ne changent pas d'avis moi ce qui
m'étonne un petit peu c'est qu'il reste
beaucoup de choses à faire à paris et en
tout cas il ya des conseillers de paris
notamment écologistes ont dit qu on
attendait sa présence moi je me promène
dans paris un alexis poulain eu du mal à
venir
on voit l'état de notre ville qui est
quand même assez catastrophique je
trouve sur le plan parfois même de la
salubrité publique et j'aurais préféré
que madame hidalgo se concentre sur
paris plutôt que d'avoir une candidature
présidentielle dont je ne comprends pas
les ressorts parce qu'en fait elle nous
sort des bons sentiments en permanence
et nous sort des éléments de langage
préparé mais dans le fond telle est son
programme on ne le connaît pas alors
certes l'élection présidentielle c'est
la relation d'un homme ou d'une femme
avec le peuple français mais je ne suis
pas certain que madame hidalgo
correspondent totalement attendre des
français alexis voilà en tout cas pas
des parisiens à ce jour en tout cas
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de colère
chez les ch et les parisiens aujourd'hui
ce qu'en dit oui le bilan
demers est compliqué alors il ya bien
sûr en ligne de mire les jeux olympiques
etc et plein plein de grands projets
comme ça le fait qu'elle soit revenu sur
sa parole bon c'est pas inédit en
politique ça s'est déjà vu après dans un
climat de défiance avec
ces gens là vivent dans un monde qui
n'est pas notre d'une certaine façon
même si on est des commentateurs de ce
monde là mais on voit bien d'ailleurs
elle a pris pour créer son équipe
rapprochée des anciens proches de manuel
valls lors de la primaire du ps donc
c'est un monde qui est en train de
s'écrouler les grands partis qui ont
bien du mal elle est candidate sans
programme évidemment elle arrive avec
cette idée de dire bon bah je vais être
une femme donc ça va être quelque chose
de bien et je suis progressiste un peu
comme emmanuel macron mais je suis quand
même du parti socialiste même si on peut
pas penser que manuel valls est encore
de gauche on l'a vu lors de ses
dernières déclarations il soutenait
valérie pécresse aux élections
régionales donc c'est dire le le fossé
évidemment rentrer les électeurs et ceux
qui aujourd'hui se présente pour pour ce
scrutin et pas de programme c'est
finalement ça choque personne je crois
qu'elle précédent emmanuel macron qui a
dit moi j'ai pas de programme j'ai un
projet donc de toutes façons on verra
bien et cette année on voit très bien
que ce soit arnaud montebourg anne
hidalgo il arrive parce qu'ils je sais
pas pour qui voter j'ai pas de programme
mais on va faire un truc va bricoler un
truc dans les mois qui viennent et puis
après on verra si ça passe c'est un peu
plus sérieux que ça quand même dans une
élection présidentielle si je peux
perdre et va falloir réconcilier aussi
la différence gauche en tout cas
arrivent à les rassembler parce que
madame hidalgo les régionales de l'année
dernière elle a eu du mal avec d'une
part une gauche indigéniste racialiste
tettey soutenu notamment par madame
pulvar elle a eu du mal à la réconcilier
avec la gauche républicaine et même
madame delga qui soutient aujourd'hui
madame hidalgo dans le cadre de la
campagne présidentielle s'était indigné
du comportement madame pulvar quant à
accepter les réunions non mixtes etc
donc je pense que madame hidalgo va
passer une campagne désastreuse où elle
va devoir s'expliquer sur tous les
sujets essayer de réconcilier des
gauches différentes et que finalement va
perdre davantage
avoir choisi finalement rester à paris
cyril martinez clairement c'est tout ce
que vous avez envie de combattre les
patriotes anne hidalgo
alors non nous ce qu'on a envie de
combattre c'est bien évidemment l'union
européenne et tout ce qu'ils savent de
plus en plus nos libertés je
souhaiterais juste rajouter quelques je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce qui a
pu être dit par maxime et par monsieur
poulin mais c'est aussi le signe
vraiment d'une défaillance d'une
désacralisation du
de la place présidentielle du prestige
présidentielle on a eu tellement de
mauvais président une mauvaise image
présidentielle depuis plusieurs
quinquennat que maintenant aujourd'hui
n'importe qui a l'impression qui peut
devenir président demain parce que ça a
été tellement rabaissé la fonction a
tellement été rabaissé qu'on voit des
candidats qui ya 20 ans mais on se
serait le poil et madame hidalgo qui se
présente à la présidentielle excusez moi
mais enfin franchement ça montre
vraiment quel niveau on atteint en
france il serait temps maman de de se
ressaisir de ce point de vue là alors
oui quand même la chance d'avoir 500
parrainages a rassemblé donc ça va
permettre de faire le tri gnac il ya
quand même bien filtre lactée qui est
difficile à pouvoir permettre mais en
tout cas pour les candidats de droite si
vous aviez des alliés bertrand michel
barnier madame pécresse et c est un
moment ils vont être obligés de se
diviser les parrainages et on est sûr
que sur le sur la ligne de départ il y
aura beaucoup moins de candidats carnet
ce jour ne parle pas beaucoup en tout
cas concernant voilà les bisbilles à
droite et les parrainages ça peut venir
finalement jouer les arbitres selon vous
je pense qu' énormément de mer et de
36000 communes un peu moins maintenant
mais il ya il ya beaucoup d'élus qui
vont attendre de la crédibilité et je
pense que des candidatures sur des
convictions vous rassembler plus
facilement des parrainages que des
candidatures comme ça de communication
c'est pour ça que michel barnier à une
candidature un peu plus souverainiste or
qu'ils essaient de revenir un peu sur
des termes différents qui travaille
beaucoup les élus locaux parce qu'il
sait qu'il va avoir besoin de ces gens
là anne hidalgo aussi c'est pour ça
qu'elle fait une candidature basée sur
les mers arnaud montebourg pour le
moment a beaucoup plus de mal à
développer cela donc je pense que la
campagne des parrainages commence
aujourd'hui elle va se terminer à peu
près au mois de mars je pense quand on
aura les circulaires officielle du
conseil constitutionnel et c'est à ce
moment là qu'on saura réellement qui
seront les candidats en lice alors autre
information à retenir en ce lundi c'est
eric zemmour en kg et privé de micro en
tout cas d'émission ces news les cartes
de l'antenne suite à la décision et
c'est ça de vouloir compter les
interventions de l'animateur comme du
temps de parole pour le candidat qu'il
n'est pas encore officiellement écoutez
sa réaction ce matin
je pense que c'est inévitable je pense
que le csa l'a fait exprès après mûre
réflexion pendant le week-end on a bien
compris que c'était la seule solution
raisonnable quand on ne peut pas
résister il faut rompre et résiste et
ailleurs
alexis soir eric zemmour qui rajoute ce
qu'on veut me faire perdre ça veut dire
qu'en fait il était
non parce que l'estac question c'est est
ce qu'il va faire un tour de france de
promo de son livre où est ce qu'il va
être candidat aujourd'hui il n'a pas
donné réponse à cette question mais là
visiblement oui alors après il est pas
privé de micro parce qu'il est invité à
peu près de partout mais évidemment sur
son émission sur ses news
il est suspendu d'antenne sur ces 2
suite à la décision du csa qui pose une
question importante parce que c'est un
précédent quand même qu'un éditorialiste
soit débranché de cette façon là en
période présidentielle alors même qu'il
n'est pas encore déclaré candidat serait
différent s'il était déclaré candidat
donc là il ya évidemment quelque chose
de l'ordre de la question de
l'organisation du débat public on voit
bien la fébrilité de la majorité avec la
volonté aussi de contrôler et censurer
les réseaux sociaux d'une certaine façon
ensuite le sait ça maintenant la loi sur
l'ingérence étrangère lors des élections
présidentielles qui est en train d'être
discutées au niveau français et au
niveau européen on sent bien qu'il ya
vraiment une volonté d'encadrer
d'assurer un débat d'une certaine façon
donc je comprends tout à fait les
critiques d'eric zemmour par rapport à
cette décision du csa maintenant il
prétend qu'il dise si oui ou non il va
être candidat mais il veut prendre son
temps évidemment et là maintenant il va
faire son tour de france pour vendre son
livre est justement et on va le voir
partout où il va être certainement
invités sur les plateaux pour présenter
son livre ça pourrait en faire un
candidat antisystème idéal maxime bouet
et finalement d'une certaine manière le
victimiser le coupé deux de ses élites
justement est peut-être lui donner un
coup de pouce je pense que c'est un fin
stratège qui sait très bien qu'il
devient le candidat antisystème parce
qu'ils avaient des moyens de contrer la
décision du csa juridiquement on était
quand même très peu fondées ils
pouvaient saisir conseil d'état en
référé et je pense que le conseil d'état
aurait été très embêté de ne pas lui
donner raison et pourtant il n'a pas
voulu faire ça répit s'est mis d'un
commun accord avec ses news à se dire je
vais partir en sorte de grand résistant
contre la meute macro nist alors ça me
fait un peu doucement sourire on verra
comment sa campagne va se décliner parce
que maintenant il est candidat
officiellement utile annonce qu'on veut
le faire perdre je ne vois pas comment
il ne peut pas être considéré comme
candidat ce qui est certain c'est
qu'eric zemmour qui au début faisait
sourire aujourd'hui devient quelqu'un de
crédible dans cette campagne
présidentielle il a un seuil à 8% et il
a un démarrage qui peut être intéressant
pour lui et surtout un pouvoir de
nuisance pour certains partis notamment
le rassemblement national c'est
peut-être de cas chez vous s'il martinez
et les patriotes il ya des idées qui se
rapproche de celle de florian philippot
vous la voyez comment vous cette
candidature qui ne dit pas son nom d'
d'eric zemmour alors si tenté qu'eric
zemmour soit candidat moi je ne peux que
m'en réjouir parce que ça va participer
peut-être davantage aux débats alors
désolé à de gaulle disait l'europe
l'europe l'europe donc je vais revenir
là dessus mais bon beaucoup de choses
des bandes de l'union européenne et je
pense que si plus on aura de candidats
qui importe un débat ne serait ce une
question sur les sur notre souveraineté
sur les lois les lois supra
supranationale que sont les lois
européennes faire prendre conscience aux
français qu' effectivement un problème
actuellement avec notre système tel
qu'il est organisé aujourd'hui tel qu'on
dépendent de plus en plus dont on dépend
de plus en plus moi je me réjouis plus
on aura de candidats souverainistes
mieux ce sera après est ce que zemmour
est souverainiste ça c'est à notre sa
note des bas mais il pose quand même des
questions intéressantes à ce sujet donc
moi je l'effective mans je l'encouragé
toute façon dans démocratie comme l'a
dit maxime tout à l'heure les 500
parrainages permettront de décret mais
certains profils peut-être moins
moins talentueux mais
effectivement si on peut apporter un
débat intéressant on va pouvoir enfin
parler de souveraineté arrêter de parler
on va faire si on va faire ça mais sans
parler une seule fois deux de ces lois
supranationale danton dépens
il n'y a rien qui change alors que là
effectivement les le fait d'avoir des
candidatures souverainiste enfin dès
qu'on va dire des candidatures
souverainiste l'on peut que s'en réjouir
donc moi j'encourage la candidature de
zemmour et de n'importe qui d'autre qui
peut porter ce débat là et faire
questionner les français justement voilà
l exemple on parlait de ce pouvoir de
nuisance eric zemmour c'est celui qui
peuvent faire perdre en tout cas la
droite dure je sais pas s'il peut faire
perdre la droite dure là ce qui peut se
passer ce qui va se passer parce qu'on
voit bien qu'il y à il ya une volonté de
recomposition du paysage politique c'est
une refondation de la droite puisque la
ligne rouge qui avaient été tracées par
jacques chirac entre l'extrême droite et
la droite
jamais vous n'irez sociale ll a commencé
déjà être un peu floue et puis là les
coûts totalement en train de bouger et
ça pourrait être
cette candidature qui va vraiment bouger
les lignes on va voir des des
ralliements déjà ce soit marine le pen
ou eric zemmour enfin peu importe mais à
droite on se pose beaucoup de questions
regardez la déclaration d'eric ciotti
lors du rassemblement des républicains
qui a dix mois au deuxième tour je
voterai et moore face à macro mais je
voudrais pas forcément le pen donc le
mouvement est déjà enclenché d'une
certaine façon un peu comme on a vu le
tea party aux états unis qui a emmené le
parti républicain qui a donné à trump
les moyens de gagner en 2016 donc je dis
pas que zemmour a les moyens de gagner
mais il a les moyens évidemment
d'accélérer une refondation de la droite
en france si je quitte mes appuis il est
sur une ligne quand même qui est très à
droite aussi un sa déclaration sur les
prénoms d'origine française c'est que je
m'attendais pas à ce qu'il aille aussi à
droite parce que moi même je vous posais
à revenir sur ceux sur cette fois là
parce que pour le coup on a quand même
des militaires français qui avaient des
noms d'origine maghrébine qui sont morts
pour la france donc je sais pas le
prénom qui fait l'assimilation je ne
crois plus je pense que c'est plutôt un
comportement c'est autre chose et
j'aurais préféré attendre entendre eric
zemmour sur ce point là mais bon ça
c'est un détail en tout cas oui eric
zemmour va être un trouble fait ça c'est
certain
deux ti et il l'allié de qui est il
l'ennemi pour le moment je pense qu'on
n'a pas la réponse l'allié de lui-même
en tout cas certainement série le marc
martinez we will très rapidement en fait
zemmour assume clairement faire une
ligne trump heist en france il suffit de
voir la couverture de son nouveau livre
c'est un copier coller de la fiche de
donald trump lorsqu'il faisait mec
america glatz gagnent donc il ya eu un
copier-coller chez zemmour une
inspiration très fortement trump heist
chez lui et il pense que
la logique trump heist va l'emporter en
france et là j'ai un peu plus de doute
parce que la france malheureusement
c'est pas les états unis et je crois
d'ailleurs qu'il a reconnue
ce aspirait ces princes pirée de la
fiche de trump pour la couverture de son
livre
elle excite poule à aux petites
informations j'aimerais vous faire
commenté c'est désormais officiel il n'y
aura pas de candidature d'edouard
philippe qui décidément est loyal à
emmanuel macron oui alors il a monté un
micro-parti néanmoins donc peut-être
qu'il voir philippe joue les
législatives où quelque chose mais ouais
enfin où vous de oui celle d'après de
toute façon depuis qu'il est au havre il
est assez protégé de tout mais peut-être
que la mise en examen d'un esprit sain
dans la cour de justice de la république
lui a rappelé que lui aussi avait été
perquisitionné et que lui aussi pourrait
se retrouver dans une situation délicate
donc une annonce aussi pour rassurer
l'exécutif et dire non j'y vais parce
qu'aussi
merci en tout cas tous les trois c'est
une martinez alexis poulin maxim
thiébaut merci d'avoir été avec nous
pour ce décryptage passionnant merci à
vous
yamoo rapidement sur les suites du
procès des attentats du 13 novembre 2015
des auditions ont repris ce matin à la
barre ce qui ont remonté la piste des
commandes aux jihadistes la cour
d'assises spéciale de paris doit
entendre un des responsables de la
sous-direction terroriste de la police
judiciaire française pour la première
fois les avocats pourront poser leurs
questions de fond ont fait le point avec
notre reporter katia technique depuis la
cour d'assises de paris
aujourd'hui le procès appelé son premier
témoin pour dévoiler les arcanes de
l'organisation des attentats un
responsable de la sdat sous direction
antiterroriste le commissaire a expliqué
le déroulé de cette nuit ensuite les
investigations d'une enquête de quatre
ans d'une ampleur considérable qui a
abouti à l'identification des
terroristes la compréhension de
l'opération avait que des fouilles très
poussé des milliers d' indice des
scellés des surveillances des géo
localisation de voitures des
interrogatoires mais c'est par exemple
une dénonciation qui a permis de cibler
la cousine d'abdelhamid à bas coûts
dacia ait bout la scène qui était chargé
de le cacher avec son complice chakib
acres où les enquêteurs se sont mis à
les filets jusqu'à l'assaut du raid dans
un immeuble de saint denis on apprend
également une information terrifiante
abdelamid about c'est le sanguinaire
celui qu'on avait vu sur une vidéo de
l'état islamique en train de traîner des
cadavres attaché à une voiture qu'il
avait prévu de commettre un attentat
dans le quartier de la défense le dise
fin novembre le commissaire a aussi
détaillé le parcours de salles abdeslam
quelques mois avant les attentats un
petit et délinquants qui sillonnaient
l'europe pour acheter des détonateurs ou
des produits d'entretien permettant de
fabriquer des explosifs salade et slam
qui a ensuite appelé deux amis belges
juste après les attentats pour le
raccompagner de paris en belgique deux
hommes qui sont évidemment dans le box
aujourd'hui des propos qui témoignent de
la sophistication des préparatifs et de
la détermination de l'état islamique à
l'époque témoignage du commissaire
interrompu par les vociférations qui
sont devenues habituelles de salah
abdeslam qui veut s'exprimer qui a dit
que ce qui était dit à la barre n'était
pas les parties civiles ce n'est pas
encore le moment du procès pour le faire
le mystère plane donc encore sur ses
intentions vis-à-vis de cette audience
et direction présent les états unis
o'donnell 3 me semble multiplié les
interventions ces derniers jours
l'ancien président américain s'est
prononcé sur plusieurs sujets comme le
sont ces dossiers de l'afghanistan notre
homme qui reproche à son successeur joe
biden d'avoir choisi de retirer les
troupes américaines au mauvais moment de
kaboul alors ses déclarations publiques
annonce-t-elle un retour en politique à
trois ans de la présidentielle
américaine la réponse avec yamina
benguigui da
pour son retour sur la scène médiatique
donald trump a choisi de ne pas retenir
ses coups à la veille de la
commémoration des attentats de 2001
si je devais boxer quelqu'un mon combat
le plus facile serait probablement joe
biden je pense qu'il tombait très très
vite il a dit une fois qu'ils aimeraient
monde derrière le bar il aurait de gros
problèmes si le faisais je pense que
byden s'effondrerait dont les premières
secondes
ce 11 septembre a également été
l'occasion pour l'ancien président de
manifester son opposition à joe biden en
proférant des propos encore plus
explicite devant des policiers dans leur
commissariat new yorkais pour donald
trump l'actuel président a choisi le
pire moment pour quitter l'afghanistan
nous tenions tout le monde nous tenions
les talibans j'ai des dossiers avec leur
chef elle était prêt à ne rien faire
sans mon accord mais soudain il ya eu
une élection truquée et tout à coup nos
troupes ont fui l'afghanistan
vous savez c'est pour ça que je pense
qu'il n'y avait pas de pire date pour
partir que ce vingtième anniversaire
nous aurions pu rester un mois de plus
ou trois ans de plus les talibans
n'aurait pas été en mesure de faire quoi
que ce soit et c'est dans ce vide que
les talibans se sont engouffrés une fois
de plus l'ex locataire de la
maison-blanche renouvelle ses
accusations à propos des dernières
élections présidentielles qu'il juge
truquée avant d'exprimer sa volonté
d'organiser une nouvelle campagne
électorale je sais ce que je vais faire
mais nous ne sommes pas censés en parler
encore du point de vue des lois sur les
financements des campagnes je pense que
vous allez être heureux laissez moi le
dire ainsi je pense que vous allez très
heureux
une campagne avant l'heure pour gêner
son ancien adversaire joe biden mais le
président en exercice a décidé de
répondre aux critiques de son adversaire
malheureux à propos de l'afghanistan
si vous aviez dit à qui que ce soit que
nous allions dépensé 300 millions $ par
jour pendant 20 ans pour waziers
d'unifier le pays
après avoir attrapé ben laden après
avoir éliminer al-qaïda là bas et ce qu
al qaïda pourrait revenir oui mais je
vous le dire ils sont déjà de retour
dans d'autres endroits
quelle est la stratégie nous devons
envahir tous les endroits où se trouve
al qaïda y laisser notre ou soyons
sérieux
le 29 février 2020 un émissaire de
donald trump avait signé avec les
talibans un texte sur le retrait des
troupes américaines d'afghanistan fixé
pour la mi mai 2021 un accord qui donner
forme à des années d'annonce initiée par
barack obama disons plutôt
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis houston aux états unis avec dave
perkins analyse politique animateur
radio c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir dave perkins merci d'être avec
nous donald trump 1 qui se fait de plus
en plus présent médiatiquement il
profite de la mauvaise passe de joe
biden pour revenir sur le devant de la
scène salon vous
donc
pour une histoire tirs qui ont préféré
mettre force lorsqu'il sera prise et je
pense autres d'après le signe qu'il est
prêt à repartir en campagne et que les
choses vont bien se passer pour un coût
de réseaux par trop brighten
effectivement un plan des kora bleus
dans de nombreux domaines qu'il s'agisse
de prix des matériaux des carburants la
devise oles une gemme et même l'armée
américaine on n'en sait rien de ces
français
effectivement cela tamerlan crainte de
profiter de sa popularité auprès de ses
partisans et popularité n'a pas baissé
au cours de la
présidence donc c'est certain tous les
trains seront campagne clos les
sélections
il a eu de très bons résultats
économiques
il aa baissé les impôts il à renforcer
l'emploi pour tous les temps et les
lieux du crime
j'étais restée exceptionnelle en tant
que président sauf bien sûr lorsqu'il
s'agit des relations avec les médias car
il n'était pas très haut niveau aux
obligations auxquelles seront confrontés
dans les médias et ont cette fois ci je
pense qu'il va tout à fait prêt
qu'il a eu le temps de se préparer
je pense que où la campagne de connaître
un peu con tre jo d'athènes en échec de
cours à beaucoup plus de succès que ce
qui s'est passé en 2020 d'expérience
vous êtes un soutien de la première
heure on l'entend bien est-ce que tout
le parking parti républicain suivra
comme un seul homme un donald trump
candidats à nouveau selon vous
le problème
républicain est divisée comme il l'était
déjà avant que donald trump remporte ses
premières élections
mais en croissance de sa base et de
soutien ce succès les ont fait réfléchir
se sont fait critiquer par la grande
partie des républicains nous faut voir
ce qu'il se passe lorsque métro mais où
d'autres républicains se dresse contre
haut et donnant en exemple ou
encore d'autres impliquant beaucoup de
républicains se sont opposés à
demontreuil côté le dépôt mais ils ont
été 1 mise au ban du parti
et des électeurs
se sont également détournés 2 et je
pense qu'aucun d'entre eux ne pourra
concourir à nouveau avec tromperie c'est
vraiment extraordinaire de voir à quel
point le parti a changé au départ ils
étaient contre trump et m'appelait
donald trump et le candidat principal
des républicains bénéficient d'une
majorité des soutiens et ses opposants
eux sont en marge du parti
il des constats en 2024 c'est évident la
majorité des électeurs républicains
seront en sa faveur on a pris ce soir
canal en s'affirmant 2 l'idéologie et de
la suprématie blanche a été arrêté avec
une baïonnette et une machette un près
du siège du parti démocrate à washington
à quelques jours d'une manifestation des
partisans de l'ancien président on va
rester prudent évidemment et pas tirer
de conclusions pour le moment on ignore
l'identité vraiment de cet homme mais
tout de même des frères qui ne certains
fans de donald trump à ce qu'ils peuvent
être nuisibles à l'ancien président et à
vous-même en tant que partisan de donald
trump ça nous inquiète
dans ce pipe
[Musique]
elle ne représente pas le danger
que prétendent les médias il ne
représente pas plus attention que les
dingues du parti démocrate qui eux aussi
sont très près mais qui sont sans doute
beaucoup plus que les fous parmi les
soutiens de donateurs
les dingues du côté démocrate ont mis le
feu à tokyo ville au milieu des états
unis en 2020 avec le soutien des médias
à utiliser qu'il s'agissait de
manifestations pacifiques a alors qu'on
voyait des flammes en arrière-plan des
images groupe
terroriste des
personnes vraiment dangereuses sont à
gauche ou plus longtemps et à une
personne dangereuse au sein des soutiens
de 30 km et peut
revenir c'est alors que matrone paix
2005 et candidat andré 24 ans fois qu'il
annonce cette candidature ce qui
arrivera bientôt je n'ai pas peur que
les soutiens de donald trump se montrent
dangereux j'ai peur que les villes
américaines soit ta santé par des
soutiens de la gauche lors de ce qu'on
appelle des manifestations pacifiques
donald trump a on l'a entendu a qualifié
jo dan didio après leur très chaotique
des troupes américaines d'afghanistan
anis temps il a reproché le timing du 11
septembre
joe biden est il le seul responsable on
se souvient il l'a dit d'ailleurs
lui-même que donald trump avait négocié
notamment cents avec les talibans en
février 2020
c'était la première partie de cette
question
par oui
la base arrière pour kaboul était
sécurisé elle aurait dû être mieux de
centralisation déco part
du reste ouverte et toutes les personnes
qui souhaitaient le parti aurait dû y
être que big up afin de pouvoir partir à
en insécurité
et au lieu de cela on l'a utilisé comme
base aérienne centre de kaboul un kit
entouré de milliers de personnes qui
pouvaient tout être des terroristes hier
donc les plans avec joe dalton aller à
l'encontre du consensus
il n'a pas pris les bonnes décisions
pour la sécurité et les gonades le
départ dont je parle comme d'afghanistan
effectivement a été fait de manière
audio et on remettra à raison du film
zéro
l'accord conclu par deux matin avait
deux conditions
les talibans devaient respecter un
certain nombre de conditions et si la
spectra alors thomas était
dire que jobs a donc été contraint par
l'accord de notre part son accord avec
les tendances étaient faux car cet
accord était déjà nulle et non avenue
car les talibans avaient violé les
termes et les talibans on n'aurait pas
fait cela c'est donald trump était
encore au pouvoir car il au premier
alors qu'il ne faille pas
je donne tu redonnes au moins lorsqu'il
clique d'accortes de l'emprunteur le lou
ye tout ce qu'a fait joe biden c'était
son propre choix merci beaucoup d'effets
perkins d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france ce soir
l'afghanistan viens d'en parler ou
antonio goûter res ne secrétaire général
de l'onu réclame une opération de
sauvetage opération surtout à
destination des populations afghanes qui
subit actuellement les conséquences du
retrait des troupes américaines et la
rupture de la chaîne humanitaire le
peuple est confronté à une importante
pauvreté face à de telles circonstances
antonio gutiérrez juge important
d'ouvrir des discussions avec les
talibans
pour le peuple afghan a besoin d'une
bouée de sauvetage après des décennies
de guerres de souffrance et d'insécurité
il est peut être confronté à son oeuvre
la plus périlleuse
aïeul jeetoo se porte en eau fraîche et
pilou je vous demande instamment de
soutenir notre appel éclair de 606
millions de dollars afin d'apporter une
aide urgente à 11 millions de personnes
au cours des quatre prochains mois nous
annonçons aujourd'hui une allocation de
20 millions de dollars du fonds central
d'intervention d'urgence des nations
unies pour soutenir l'opération
humanitaire en afghanistan l'opération
en afghanistan et pour ses opérations
humanitaires l'afghanistan besoin de 600
millions de dollars d'urgence un appel
aux donateurs a été lancée mardi dernier
par l'onu la conférence s'est tenue
aujourd'hui à genève pour recueillir les
promesses de dons les listes ont
contrôlé est confronté pardon à
l'effondrement de ses services de base
dus au gel des aides financières
internationales farah mais qui
un appel à l'aide du milieu sanitaire
afghan depuis la prise de pouvoir du
pays par les talibans la communauté
internationale a interrompu le
financement du projet seat mendient
mises en places en 2018 ce programme
avait pour ambition d'accroître
l'utilisation et la qualité des services
de santé de nutrition et de
planification familiale en afghanistan
c'est ce tome à 4,6 au sénat sur la loi
la communauté internationale devrait pas
politiser le secteur de la santé il ne
devrait pas interrompre leur aide au
secteur de la santé beau jude law matt
manson des millions de citoyens afghans
seront privés de soins de santé
mastrov des oui et nous allons perdre
beaucoup de femmes ce qui est inquiétant
pour tout le monde onze ans reste
une aide internationale cruciale pour le
secteur sanitaire afghans grâce au
projet seat mendient plus de vingt mille
agents de santé avaient les moyens
d'exercer dans le pays un gel des
financements qui pourrait ainsi
entraîner la fermeture de plus de 2000
centres médicaux soit 90 % des
établissements selon l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
c'est un pays qui a cruellement besoin
d'assistance humanitaire is dead pour
stabiliser les infrastructures et les
services de base il a besoin de soutien
international s'il a besoin d'engagement
plus nous souhaitons influencer de
manière positive ce que le nouveau
gouvernement afghan décide plus nous
aurons besoin d'engagements
en 2020 plus de 30 millions d'adultes
afghan et un million et demi d'enfants
ont bénéficié des services de santé
fournis dans le cadre du projet seat
mendy ils sont désormais privés de soins
médicaux et sous pour une durée
indéterminée
[Musique]
accord trouvé entre téhéran et l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique il
concerne la surveillance du programme
nucléaire iranien les inspecteurs de
l'aiea pourront désormais accéder aux
caméras placées au sein des
installations nucléaires de la
république islamique
un signe d'espoir dans les négociations
suspendues pour l'instant autour de
l'accord de vienne marcel pluviaux
il est venu en personne pour relancer
des négociations qui n'avançait plus à
téhéran le directeur général de l'iowa
et le chef de l'organisation iranienne
de l'énergie atomique ont enfin trouvé
un terrain d'entente sur une question
cruciale la surveillance vidéo des
installations iraniennes alors que
l'iran a restreint en février l'accès
des inspecteurs de l'agencé à certains
de ces sites ces derniers pourront
désormais y pénétrer pour mettre à jour
ses équipements il ya craignez de perdre
des données en cas de saturation de la
mémoire des caméras de surveillance
aujourd'hui nous sommes en mesure
d'avoir un résultat très concrète au lit
qui permet la continuité du
fonctionnement des équipements de
lagence
[Musique]
which is est indispensable pour que nous
puissions fournir les garanties et les
informations nécessaires à la loi
ainsi qu'au monde entier que tout est en
ordre
pour l'instant sim de bonne volonté
l'iran va permettre aux caméras de
surveillance de l'aiea de continuer à
enregistrer sans pour autant donner
l'accès aux enregistrements je rappelle
que l'ensemble des activités menées par
l'iran sont pacifiques les yeux à
poursuivre à ces inspections et sa
surveillance conformément à l'accord de
garantie
raphaël grossi le directeur général de
l'aïe et hoa sera bientôt de retour en
iran pour des consultations de haut
niveau mais sans accès au contenu des
enregistrements des sites iraniens
détenue exclusivement par téhéran
l'organisme de surveillance se retrouve
cependant dans la même position depuis
février les négociations concernant le
retour des etats-unis dans l'accord de
vienne de 2015 sont toujours au point
mort un accord qui offre à téhéran un
allègement des sanctions occidentales en
échange d'une réduction drastique de son
programme nucléaire après le retrait
américain des négociations annoncées par
donald trump en 2018 téhéran a décidé de
ne plus respecter ses obligations depuis
les etats unis ont accepté de revenir à
la table des discussions des discussions
de nouveau suspendue deux jours après la
victoire à la présidentielle iranienne
débrayera ici le 18 juin dernier
le développement du nucléaire iranien vu
comme une menace par certains pays dont
pour en parler nous sommes avec taux de
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir quand je fais
sans merci d'être avec nous est ce qu'on
peut parler ce soir de réelles pas en
avant pour l'avenir de l'accord de
vienne est possible reprise des
discussions
c'est manifestement un succès pour
monsieur grossi le directeur général de
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
atomique qui siège à vienne il a obtenu
de son interlocuteur iranien mais
nouveau chef de l'agencé nucléaire
iranienne nommé par le gouvernement au
gouvernement en effet que les les
inspecteurs de l'aï va puisse tenir très
régulièrement faire la maintenance de
leurs caméras de leur matériel de
surveillance changer les disques durs
lorsque c'est nécessaire mais comme on
l'a dit dans votre sujet ils n'auront
pas pour autant accès au contenu des
enregistrements
le contenu des enregistrements c'est
lorsque l'accord de 2015 fonctionnera à
nouveau et lorsque les états unis et les
autres pays
respecteront leurs engagements et que et
que l'iran rentrera aussi dans le cadre
de ses engagements donc c'est un sur le
plan technique c'est un accord limité je
crois que c'est important sur le plan
humain parce que ça veut dire que les
inspecteurs de la u avant régulièrement
aller dans les installations nucléaires
iraniennes qu'ils vont nouer des
contacts que le directeur général
lui-même va retourner régulièrement en
iran et discuter avec les responsables
politiques et ça je crois que c'est une
une chose extrêmement positive quel est
l'enjeu de l'intervention de ses
inspecteurs de l'aiea sur l'équipement
nucléaire est ce qu'on doit s'attendre à
quelque chose de différent presse est
cet accord pas vraiment puisque c'est un
geste de bonne volonté que fait le
nouveau gouvernement
iranien ce geste est tout bénéfice pour
lui puisqu'il ne lui coûte pas grand
chose les inspecteurs n'ont pas accès au
contenu des enregistrements mettant
enregistrements seront faits et stocker
jusqu au jour où au miracle l'accord
sera à nouveau en vigueur alors
effectivement ils l'ont fait les vire
anien pour marquer qu'eux ils étaient
prêts à poursuivre la négociation et que
ce gouvernement dans tout le monde dit
qu'il est beaucoup plus dur que le
précédent puisque en effet les élections
du 18 juin on donnait un résultat
favorable conservateur donc aux gens
beaucoup plus dur et ils veulent montrer
que ils veulent continuer la négociation
mais naturellement il montre aussi que
si les négociations échouent en raison
notamment l'exigence américaine pour
rentrer dans l'accord eh bien ce ne sera
pas de leur fait ce sera la
responsabilité des américains les
américains veulent plus que l'accord de
2015 alors que les iraniens veulent un
retour à l'accord de 2015 purement et
simplement en échange de la levée des
sanctions occidentales enfin des
sanctions qui ont été mises à lorsque
les américains sont sortis de l'accord
c'est pour ça qu'ils le font c'est ça
l'intérêt de l'iran que la pression
internationale retombe les sanctions
avec bien sûr et veulent que les
sanctions soient levés elodie d'ailleurs
le les sanctions sont très très brutal
l'économie est exergue la population
souffre beaucoup c'est pas pour autant
qu'elle se soulève contre le régime la
preuve est là et lieux des gens plus
conservateur que précédemment donc les
sanctions ne perd pas comme les auteurs
des sanctions auraient souhaité qu'elle
opère et en fait effectivement le
gouvernement et de vendeurs de lever ses
sanctions mais il veut pas payer trop
cher il veut revenir purement et
simplement dans ses engagements
2 juillet 2015 pas plus ce que demandent
en plus et américains c'est qu'on
mentionne dans l'ordre la reprise de
l'accord que les sujets balistiques sont
maintenant très important qu'il faudra
en discuter et que aussi le rôle que
joue l'iran dans la région à travers ces
milices pro iranienne donc les
ingérences dans les affaires intérieures
des pays voisins soit un sujet qu'ils
puissent faire l'objet de discussions
d'ailleurs les iraniens ne sont pas cons
entre discuter ces sujets a simplement
ils veulent pas que ça ne figure dans le
nouvel accord alors vous restez c'est
avec mon si vous le voulez bien que de
blanche maison puisqu'on vend évoqué
ensemble un autre sujet d'actualité sur
le front du nucléaire si l'iran on l'a
vue semble qu'au père et la corée du
nord en revanche elle ne compte pas non
plus réduire son programme nucléaire qui
en auraient testé avec succès un nouveau
missile de croisière l'ont portée c'est
ce qu'a annoncé hier soir l'agencé
officielle nord-coréenne le pays
continue donc ses essais d'armes
technique malgré les sanctions
internationales
le japon s'est dit aujourd'hui très
préoccupé dans un communiqué le
pentagone a dit de son côté dénoncé un
développement continu par la corée du
nord de son programme nucléaire donc le
mien qui procède à son troisième
lancement
pourquoi ces nouveaux tirs déjà les
résolutions de l'onu interdisent à la
corée du nord de faire des tirs
balistiques mais elles n'interdisent pas
de faire des essais sur des fusées
de quoi de croisière des missiles de
croisière qui le vol à très basse
altitude qui d'ailleurs sont difficiles
à repérer pour cette raison alors que
les missiles balistiques vont au delà de
l'atmosphère et qu'on peut les repérer
beaucoup plus facilement d'ailleurs les
américains comme les sud coréens ont dit
qu'il n'avait pas repéré ces tirs ils
ont été annoncés très calmement par l'
agence de la corée du nord dans la
journée d'aujourd'hui alors les japonais
sont très inquiet parce que la portée de
ces tirs d'après l'agencé nord coréenne
ces 1500 km ça veut dire que l'essentiel
du territoire du japon pourrait être
touchée par des missiles de croisière de
ce type donc le japon veut se protéger
par un bouclier antimissile très
efficace et les discussions déjà très
ancienne avec les américains à ce sujet
la corée du sud est est très embarrassée
parce que elle reçoit demain monsieur
wang le ministre des affaires étrangères
de la chine et peut-être qu'on peut se
demander d'ailleurs si les coréens du
nord n'ont pas choisi cette date pour
embarrasser la chine pour la mettre au
pied du mur puisque la chine
traditionnellement protège cet allié
incommode qui est la corée du nord et
bien que va-t-elle répondre aux
questions de la corée du sud qui pour
elle un partenaire économique très
important alors en tout cas un
washington dénonce justement un des
menaces vous parlez des voisins pesant
sur les voisins de la corée du nord et
la communauté internationale est ce
qu'on peut s'attendre à des
détériorations une détérioration des
relations diplomatiques entre la corée
du nord et les etats-unis qui s'étaient
réchauffées an plus tôt avec donald
trump alors la corée du nord n'a pas de
relations diplomatiques avec beaucoup de
pays mais en effet donald trump avait
bien qu'il n'est pas rétabli la scène
diplomatique près initiative très
spectaculaire qui était d'aller négocier
tout seul pratiquement sans aucune
préparation avec kim jong-un et ça a
donné les résultats que l'on connaît
c'est à dire que ça n'a pas marché en
réalité on pas bien que d'abord il ya
deux situations politiques probablement
difficile à pyongyang avec un problème
de succession qui se profile
on parle beaucoup de la soeur de kim
jong il de kim jong-un pardon qui
apparemment joue un rôle politique
important et qui se verrait bien dans la
rolls le rôle de la jce de la succession
de de kim jong-un bon je crois que en
effet la tendance va être de renforcer
les sanctions puisque la corée du nord
poursuit dans une voie belliqueuse
est-ce que c'est ces essais sont
fréquents en corée du nord et qu'est-ce
qu'ils veulent montrer qu est ce qu ils
veulent dire ils ont toujours une
signification une signification
politique d'abord le le timing est
toujours très important et on voit où on
va dire derrière voulait folle et des
images impressionnantes ont le sens de
la communication effectivement du régime
nord-coréen voilà et la même n'hésite
pas à mettre dans l'embarras alors leur
principal protecteur la chine puisque la
date a été choisie pour cela et donc
tous les essais nucléaires les essais
balistiques et maintenant les missiles
de croisière sont toujours faits à des
dates précises pour répondre à une
préoccupation politique là c'était aussi
pour répondre à des manoeuvres qui avait
eu lieu dans avec la corée
là entre la corée et ses alliés dans les
mers voisine est naturellement à chaque
fois qu'il ya des manoeuvres militaires
impliquant la corée du sud la corée du
nord fait un test année c'est quelqu'un
quel qu'il soit pour démontrer qu'elle
est là est en effet sans doute pour dire
moi je veux je suis prêt à discuter mais
à discuter
de façon réaliste c'est à dire je veux
qu'on garantisse l'existence de l'état
corée du nord pour le moment celle armes
nucléaires qui ma meilleure garantie il
faut me donner une autre garantie et
parmi celles ci la dénucléarisation de
la presqu'île coréenne merci claude à
blanche faisant nous avoir apporté votre
éclairage
et on l'a évoqué il ya quelques minutes
parmi les voix qui s'élèvent depuis
toujours face au développement du
nucléaire iranien celle d'israël le
premier ministre israélien qui était en
déplacement aujourd'hui dans la région
naftali bennett s'est entretenu au caire
avec le président égyptien d'elle un
fatal si si dans la station balnéaire de
charm el cheikh sur la mer rouge c'était
la toute première visite officielle d'un
premier ministre israélien en égypte
depuis 2010 les discussions ont porté
sur le processus de paix ou encore les
projets régionaux et internationaux
c'est un père charbit corruption
je viens de terminer ma première visite
avec le président égyptien une rencontre
importante et positive au cours de la
réunion nous avons établi une
infrastructure pour une connexion
profonde pour le reste du chemin nous
avons discuté de toute une série de
questions dans le domaine politique dans
le domaine de la sécurité dans le
domaine économique et des moyens
d'approfondir la relation est de
renforcer les intérêts de nos pays
israël s'ouvre au pays de la région et
la base de cette reconnaissance de
longue date et la paix entre israël et
l'egypte par conséquent ce des deux
côtés nous devons investir dans le
renforcement de cette relation est ce
que nous avons fait aujourd'hui par
conséquent des deux côtés nous devons
investir dans le renforcement de cette
relation et c'est ce que nous avons fait
aujourd'hui 14 vas tu as i noya rester
avec nous dans quelques instants ce soir
dans notre rubrique qu'en pensent les
fronts c'est notre heure rapporte à la
scène rap est allé à la rencontre de
clara bouaziz elle a perdu son père au
tout début de la pandémie elle fait
partie des quatorze mille cinq cents
personnes qui ont déposé plainte auprès
de la cour de justice de la république
alors l'état est il responsable nous
tenterons d'y répondre dans notre face à
face
[Musique]
le volontarisme politique atteint ses
limites dans les français sont de plus
en plus sceptique
[Musique]
à
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
est ce qu'il ya une période de stabilité
en haïti est ce que ça a été est ce que
ça existe et je la fais plus de cent ans
que l'on avait assisté à l'assassinât
d'un président de la république a mighty
l'état de droit a été véritablement mis
à mal pour permettre l'assassinât sur un
mode crapuleux l'on a vu en fait se
constituer des armées privées qui
aujourd'hui ont totalement perdu le
contrôle de leur trou et lorsque ces
gangsters sont recrutés par des hommes
politiques ça vous donne une situation
pratiquement de guerre civile nous
sommes ici au coeur d'un système
extrêmement un briquet d'intérêt à la
fois intérieure et extérieure de toute
façon
mafieux cela ne peut que contribuer à la
dé construction d'un état moderne et
démocratique
[Musique]
ce que vous répondez quand on vous
soupçonne et on soupçonne votre
industrie d'être sulfureuse
d'industriels et extrêmement contrôlée
pourquoi puisque on reverse 50 5 % de
notre chiffre d'affaires à l'état et à
la commune ils sont donc très intéressé
au fait que le fonctionnement soit clean
on fait exactement comme les banques les
compagnies d'assurances comme il ya
d'argent suspects nous sommes dans
l'obligation de déclarer comment se
répartit 100 euros de mise globalement
aux machines à sou par exemple moi j'ai
dans l'obligation de vendre en moyenne
85% nous on n'a absolument aucun intérêt
à ce que quelqu'un aille raconter il
sert huilée au casino pas certains vous
pouvez dépenser des sommes extrêmement
importantes allant jusqu'aux millions
d'euros aujourd'hui ça n'existe et on
est beaucoup plus dans le loisir
aujourd'hui ce qui fait notre marge
c'est la fréquentation et le nombre
le résultat d'un jeu peut réserver bien
des surprises pour mieux comprendre où
vous aideront à y voir clair
[Musique]
louis saillant est un ex commandos
marine il nous emmène dans les coulisses
de la guerre contre le djihadisme au
sahel l'ennemi l'abord est parfaitement
légitime on parle de jay liste on parle
de gens qui recrutent des enfants on
parle de gens qui sont d'une barbarie
extrême c'est vrai que c'est un terreau
qui peut favoriser
l'extension du terrorisme ne faut pas
imaginer qu'il suffit simplement d'avoir
un pays pauvre pour que l'islam c'est un
an lire mac sont embrigadés ils ont été
séduits ils ont été manipulés et
d'autres qui agissent de manière
parfaitement consciente et lucide je
respecterai toujours
l'adversaire même si je méprise
totalement son idéologie comme c'est le
cas pour sega liste
mais
[Musique]
il est 20 heures merci de nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième partie d'émission
place notre désormais être autour d'un
rendez-vous qu'en pensent les français
dans quelques instants nous sommes allés
ce soir à la rencontre de cette femme
clara bouaziz elle a perdu son père tout
au début de la pandémie elle fait partie
des plus de 14000 1 500 plaignants qui
ont déposé plainte auprès de la cour de
justice de la république
plusieurs ministres ou anciens membres
du gouvernement sont visées pour leur
gestion de la pandémie
[Musique]
et avant d'évoquer ces plaintes et leurs
fonds dans un point sur la situation
sanitaire en france avec trois mille
classes fermées pour cause de comics 19
depuis la rentrée scolaire annonce du
ministre de l'éducation nationale jean
michel blanquer dans un entretien au
parisien un chiffre comptabilisé
seulement huit jours après la rentrée la
semaine dernière il est passé à 545 un
chiffre qui risque d'augmenter dans les
prochains jours avant de se stabiliser
redescendre selon le ministre dans le
même temps la vaccination des plus de 12
ans poursuit avec des propositions dans
tous les établissements scolaires d'ici
la fin du mois et si les tests
deviendront payants partir du 15 octobre
et resteront gratuits en milieu scolaire
et en parallèle la campagne de rappel
vaccinal antico vida député débuté ce
matin dans les ehpad l'injection d'une
troisième dose de sérum pour faire
grimper les anticorps des personnes à
risque au total 600 mille résidents des
maisons de retraite sont concernés
et la gestion de la pandémie au coeur
des débats alors que l'ancien ministre
agnès buzyn vient d'être mise en examen
pour mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
de nombreuses plaintes continuent à être
déposés ont fait le point en images
[Musique]
pour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
oui
[Musique]
et
alors l'état at il failli dans la prise
en charge des français durant la crise
du coc vite qu'en pensent les français
eux mêmes nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de clara bouaziz elle a donc
perdu son père au début de la pandémie
son histoire et poignant que vous allez
l'entendre clara fait partie de ces
français qui ont porté plainte contre
plusieurs ministres devant la cour de
justice de la république
esther fa estelle farges est allé à sa
rencontre en plein coeur de paris
reportage
je suis dans un immeuble du 4e
arrondissement de la capitale derrière
cette porte clara bouaziz elle a perdu
son papa décédé en avril 2020 des suites
du coc vide
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour carrare merci de nous
recevoir faire a dit nous racontez nous
ce qui vous est arrivé
bon alors ce qui nous est arrivé
s'est passé au début de la première
partie de l'épidémie mon frère ma mère
mon père on attrape locaux vides vers
mars et ils ont été malades
hospitalisés mon père est décédé du coc
vide si vous le voulez nous pouvons
continuer
kara comment s'est déroulée la prise en
charge de votre papa qu'ils sont venus
ils sont constater que ma mère et mon
père était malade et ils n'ont pris que
mêmes erreurs pourquoi ton séparer ce
couple de personnes âgées malades tous
les deux on les a séparés ils s'étaient
mariés depuis 60 ans et mon père a
préparé les affaires de ma mère pour
aller à l'hôpital mais on l'a laissé
qu'est ce qui s'est passé après alors
après j'ai rappelé en a rappelé deux
jours plus tard
pour mon père parce qu'il se plaignait
de ne pas bien respirer et mon père
détestait l'hôpital un don qu'il n'avait
jamais été à l'hôpital
et là il m'a dit non non je crois que il
faut faut y avait là et
donc on a appelé la préparer ses
affaires et il est parti à l'hôpital
on voit leur papa et transporté à
l'hôpital et là qu'est ce qui se passe
je ne sais pas si c'est le troisième
jour le quatrième jour on va lui faire
une piqûre est là cette piqûre cette
injection à va être fatale c'est une
injection d'anxiolytiques et de
morphiniques vous avez pu dire au revoir
à votre papa non non non je lui ai pas
dit au revoir on nous appelait en nous
disant que ça y est il allait partir
mais sur mon frère sont allés moi j'ai
su ballet parce que je je n'y croyais
pas on peut vous dire
je voulais pas dit non je viendrai pas
parce que tu ne vas pas mourir je le
connais mon père redonne vie à tous mon
père vous pouviez lui donner trois
plantes qu'on trouvait mort d'ib un mois
après boulet elle était là avec des
floraisons quoi un objet cassé et
reprenaient vite ou reprenent évidence
des pas possible que mon père meurt et
enfin il n'aurait pas dû mourir ça c'est
un fait c'est sûr et certain
qu'est ce qu'il ya au-delà du coc vis du
virus
c'est la prise en charge qui a été
mauvaise selon vous c'est les premiers
soins
oui c'est la prise en charge de tout
depuis le début c'est à dire que quand
l'épidémie arrive personne ne nous
prévient qu'il y à une épidémie personne
ne nous prévient de la contagiosité
personnes nous nous prévient du danger
inquiets les masques il ya les tests
donc vous vous demandez pourquoi avoir
mis tant de temps pour accéder au test
pour qu'on ait le droit de faire des
tests tous les jours j'appelais mais
s'il vous plaît les tests les thèses et
et je disais mais passer au delà
n'attendait pas l'agrément il faut
sauver mes parents vont mourir les gens
sont en train de mourir qu'est-ce qu'on
attend qu'est ce qu'on attend mais ces
dépenses et des enjeux pauline des
enjeux politiques des enjeux d'argent
aussi 'cependant dans tous les autres
pays on se battait pour sauver les
citoyens ici on était dans des palabres
et des petits des petites mèches basses
de jeu politique et jeux d'argent
pendant que les gens mouraient quoi tout
simplement c'est cette prise en charge
elle et elle n'est pas venue on aurait
dû être protégé par l'état vous avez
décidé d'intenter
une action en justice oui oui j'ai
j'attends une action en justice contre
la contre l'état d'une part puis contre
l'hôpital et contre le samu oui j'ai
déjà aidé quelques documents s'y montrer
mais s'ils voulaient me suis
[Musique]
dit ça c'est le premier document que
j'ai reçus en fait c'est ma convocation
pour la cour de justice vous avez déposé
trois clans oui contrôle et haletante
mais c'est nul contre l'hôpital oui au
oui/non d'eads s'est plaint alors
j'attends oui oui j'attends qu'on trouve
les responsables j'attends que que
justice entre guillemets soit faite mon
père est décédé
malheureusement notre famille encore a
subi une déflagration
et elle n'est pas venu comme ça donc
voilà je veux que justice soit faite qui
est normal
vous êtes au travail vous commettez une
faute un impair
il y à des responsables où sont les
responsables je veux que justice soit
faite on vient d'entendre clara bouaziz
justement est ce que l'état peut être
tenu pour responsable
ce qui nous amène un débat un peu plus
philosophique peut-être la politique
sanitaire doit elle être jugés par les
magistrats ou bien par les électeurs
c'est l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler ce soir jean
philippe du goût amer udi de même si
bonsoir jean philippe dugoin vous êtes
également vice président de la région
ile-de-france à vos côtés pour en
débattre aurélien lecoq porte parole de
la france insoumise bonsoir à tous les
deux merci d'être avec nous pour revenir
tout d'abord sur ces mises en examen la
majorité embarrassé a notamment dans la
mise en examen de l'ancien ministre de
la santé je vous propose d'écouter le
commentaire de ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire s'était ce matin chez nos
confrères d'el c'est
moi ce qui m'inquiète ce n'est pas la
judiciarisation de la politique mais la
judiciarisation de la démocratie une
ligne rouge a été franchie
jean philippe dugoin clément on a vu pas
mal d'embarras avec cette mise en main
en examen daniel musée vous quelle est
votre position sur ce sujet
non je comprends que le gouvernement
soit les gens avaient fait de cette
situation et à huit mois d'une
présidentielle et on voit qu'il ya
potentiellement un fils une pelote qui
peut être tiré exploiter politiquement
au delà de ça il ya deux sujets qui se
posent là dessus la première c'est la
responsabilité est collective
administrative d'une structure qu'il
s'agit de l'état d'une collectivité
locale d'un hôpital très bien ce qu'il
co logique d'indemnisation de recherche
de responsabilités et puis la deuxième
chose ce qui se produit ici et qui pour
le coup m'interpelle beaucoup plus c'est
la responsabilité est personnelle d'une
ministre 28 qu personnelles sur des
choix politiques n'étant pas des choix
délictuelle n'étant pas le fait de doute
repasser une réglementation de ne pas
respecter une réglementation est donc
alors même qu'une crise est en cours et
n'est pas terminée on est aujourd'hui
quasiment seul pays à rentrer sur ce
type d'action galles italie mais il ya
le pays dans le monde qui le fou ce qui
a été montré lé témoignage vous avez
enregistré et bouleversant mais des
témoignages clic on peut retrouver dans
énormément pays parce que je train sur
ce type d'action le fait de rentrer sur
une mise en cause d'une responsabilité
pénale d'un élu mais on exactement la
même chose sur un air avec un arbre qui
va tomber avec c'est l'histoire du
panier de basket qui tombe et qui blesse
quelqu'un ces cabanes décisions
politiques 1 jean-philippe du coin
clémente aussi on peut toujours
retrouver une décision politique parce
qu'on va vous dire que ça m'a pas été
entretenues et eu un défaut de
surveillance y ait un défaut d'entretien
est ce qu'ils se posent là c'est la
généralisation de ce qu'on appelait le
syndrome furiani à une époque qui risque
et qui peut c'était d'ailleurs décrit
par le secrétaire général du conseil
constitutionnel tout simplement aboutir
à une cessation de l'action politique
encore un élu va avoir pour principal
souci dans une prise de décision de
chercher à se couvrir de chercher à
limiter une responsabilité politique
ultérieur je suis pas convaincu que
l'action politique à démocratie fait un
nom par aurélien lecoq vous partager
cette opinion
c'est pas moi de juger si la mise en
examen est légitime ou pas si la cour de
justice de la république a décidé qu'il
devait y avoir mise en examen et ce
n'est pas un jugement il y aura jugement
derrière on verra s'il considère que ce
que craignaient du sein est responsable
et coupable et juridiquement de quelque
chose mais c'est pas à moi d'en juger
après on parle de la question de la
responsabilité pénale des hommes et des
femmes politiques qui ont été en
fonction
effectivement tant d'autres dans notre
pays c'est comme ça personne n'est au
dessus des lois et en l'occurrence la
non-assistance à personne en danger est
effectivement un délit et tout le monde
peut en être responsable c'est
effectivement le cas de ceux qui nous
gouvernent des membres du gouvernement
le cas effectivement d'élus locaux mais
souvent vous aimez faire des parallèles
avec la vie réelle les entreprises les
petits commerçants mais c'est le cas de
tout le monde tout citoyen français est
pénalement responsable
de ses actes alors dans le cas d'espèce
sous c'est pas la politique qui doit
être jugée si à un moment on considère
que agnès buzyn avait des éléments
qu'elle était en capacité de steam est
un danger et qu à l'arc et qu'elle n'a
pas réagi pour des raisons diverses et
variées par exemple parce que ça coûtait
trop cher ou une autre raison si c'est
le cas alors oui c'est quoi et oui c'est
normal qu'il puisse y avoir un jugement
mais si ce n'est pas le cas alors elle
ne sera pas elle ne sera pas rendu
coupable mais si la justice décide de se
saisir de la faire il faut que ça puisse
aller que ça puisse aller aujourd'hui 41
ans après ce qui est vrai c'est que ce
n'est pas agnès buzyn d'être le fusible
du gouvernement et de la débâcle du
gouvernement sur la gestion de la crise
qu vide il faut aussi que chacun assume
ses responsabilités y compris le
président de la république et que lui il
assume ses responsabilités de manière
politique en arrêtant de prendre
l'ensemble des décisions sous le couvert
du secret défense est utile se rendent
par exemple devant le parlement pour
pouvoir rendre compte des décisions
qu'il prend jean-philippe pas du moins
clément justement
notre ami parler de deux fusibles sur la
même ligne d'ailleurs que bruno le maire
bernard henri lévy lui dénoncé un climat
de populisme général est ce que
justement pour reprendre donc ce terme
est ce qu agnès buzyn est un fusible un
bouc-émissaire nous sommes dans une
enclume de populisme pénal il faut entre
guillemets pardonnez moi l'expression se
payer des politiques
et j'en sais rien après ce qu'est ce qui
est fait à ce qu'elle déguise un
ministre d'un gouvernement qui comprend
un ministre et le premier ministre qui
est nommé par le président de république
dans une concentration des pouvoirs et
un exercice d'iter concentration du
pouvoir qu'on a jamais connu depuis la
création de la vème république et
portant pouvoir ultra centralisé
et évidemment si agnès buzyn
elise en cause ou attaquer l'une manière
ou d'une autre on peut imaginer que ça
commence à tirer une pelote de laine ce
qui est extrêmement gênant pour ce
gouvernement met véritablement pour moi
la question font là dessus c'est
quasiment un débat philosophique je
lisais
l'autre intervenant sait s'il ya une
irrégularité quelque chose qui a été
cachée très bien si ça n'est pas le cas
qu'on est sur le choix d'une action ou
une appréciation politique dans quelle
mesure est sûre juge de se substituer à
l'électeur pour aller à postériori juge
est de savoir si les décisions qui ont
été prises ont été bonnes ou mauvaises
et le glissement on peut hein crainte
qui peut être risqué c'est celui-là a
posteriori quelle est la responsabilité
individuelle de quelqu'un qui aura pris
des prises de position pour tel ou tel
type de soins pour tel ou tel type
d'action pour tel ou tel type de
protocole dans des établissements
publics c'est ça qui peut se poser
derrière et au fond le risque c'est quoi
c'est que vous ayez un des ministres qui
le jour où il se retrouve nommé en poste
à une fonction fois dans une logique de
lanaken la couverture systématique en
disant chacun de leur acte politique
pourra donner à mieux à une mise en
cause juridique et pénales c'est ça qui
est dangereux dans ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui sur l'europe pour le reste
effectivement
est il des logements qui seront
je comprends bien je comprends bien ce
que vous dites mais vous le dites vous
même si on arrive à démontrer le fait
qu'il ya une mise en danger et
consciente de la vie d'autrui parce
qu'il y avait des informations connues
qui n'ont pas été utilisés correctement
vous trouvez que c'est normal qu'il
puisse y avoir condamnation là en
l'occurrence il n'ya pas condamnation
j'imagine que les juges s'ils ont décidé
d'une mise en examen parce qu il avait
reçu de très nombreuses plaintes c'est
qu'ils ont considéré qu'il fallait que
l' enquête se poursuivre et que il y
avait déjà des éléments qui nécessitait
une poursuite de l'enquêté pour
l'instant elle n'est pas condamné mais
pour pouvoir répondre à la question que
vous avez posé il faut bien que non que
l' enquête puisse se dérouler à charge
et à décharge mais c'est le principe de
notre justice aujourd'hui il ne faut pas
que les affaires politiques et le débat
politique se règle devant les tribunaux
et on est les premiers à le dire puisque
même on nous a renvoyés devant les
tribunaux donc il faut pas qu'ils se
passent devant les tribunaux mais il
faut aussi que la justice puisse faire
son travail et que les hommes et les
femmes politiques ne soient pas au
dessus des lois donc nous verrons bien
ce que l' enquête va donner et quel que
soit le résultat de l'enquète et quel
que soit le résultat à la fin pour agnès
buzyn ce qui est sûr c'est que de notre
côté nous nous pouvons dire que
politiquement il ya eu un problème que
politiquement cette crise a été mal géré
et quand on voit que emmanuel mac os
continuent à supprimer des vies pendant
la crise que l'année dernière il a
encore supprimé 1800 les 1800 lit alors
qu'on nous sommes en pleine crise
sanitaire qui en avait supprimé 4,6 me
l'année précédente commente à 5000 lits
supprimés sur 20 ans il ya un problème
politique de fond auxquels ces gens ou
aussi participé et dont ils devront
rendre des comptes cette fois là
peut-être pas dans la justice mais
devant le peuple français justement
c'est ce type de décision parler de
l'augmentation des lits qui aurait pu
peut-être éviter certains drames comme
on l'a vu dans ce témoignage de gens il
faut bien dire parce que c'est pas le
premier que l'on entend tous qui sont
morts seuls sont leurs familles si les
hôpitaux étaient mieux gérer est ce que
c'est votre opinion aussi jean philippe
dugoin témoins
oui enfin il n'y a pas que le sujet les
est aussi un élément parmi d'autres -
trentenaire ça fait 18 mois que j'ai pu
vivre les incohérences le l'état sur
beaucoup de sujets l'un des sujets
décideurs ne dépend pas de ce
gouvernement pas d'aujourd'hui il c'est
la paupérisation ou la limitation des
moyens hospitaliers auxquels on a été
confronté encore une fois très
objectivement je suis pas convaincu que
la situation de l'hôpital aujourd'hui
uniquement de la question et de la
situation de madame busin voit là est
le véritable débat qui va se poser c'est
à une situation politique à la façon
dont a été gérée ou non gérer une crise
politique mans revient une réponse
politique et cette réponse politique
elle doit avoir lieu dans les urnes elle
doit avoir lieu en avril prochain et en
juin prochain mais je pense que la
judiciarisation du débat politique et
faire quelque chose qui est extrêmement
dangereux et pour revenir à ce que vous
disiez alors dans le cas de la france
insoumise on n'est pas lié à l'exercice
des pouvoirs là on n'est pas sur une
attaque de monsieur mélenchon par
rapport aux prises de position
politiques qui sont les siennes c'est ce
qui si on va sur le grill ici une
juridication du pouvoir par bon excusez
moi pourrait être le cas et c'est ça que
je trouve ces glissements que je trouve
dangereux encore une fois et dernière
chose encore une fois s'il doit y avoir
une mise en cause d'un ministre sur ce
sujet je peux le concevoir je pouffe
rendent extrêmement tôt pour le faire
la crise de la comida n'est pas terminé
on demande au ministre de la santé qui a
succédé à man à buzeins de continuer à
gérer cette crise on demandera au
successeur de monsieur verrons dans
quelques mois de continuer à gérer cette
crise comment le ministre de la santé
qui sera en poste pour succéder à
monsieur virant au made in usa va être
amené à gérer une crise sachant que son
ou ses prédécesseurs sont poursuivis en
justice c'est juste la question que je
pose et je pense que
je pense que en allant trop vite on met
tout simplement la capacité de réaction
et d'action des parents j'ai
simplement vous dire qu'il y avait un
moyen aussi peut-être pour que l'on en a
il fallait c'est celui d'avoir vendu des
comptes politiques pendant la crise
pourquoi aujourd'hui il ya eu des
centaines dans des milliers de plaintes
contre le gouvernement parce que le
gouvernement ne rendez vous il ya des
rires de réponse trop lui
réponse politique devant le peuple
peut-être que si les décisions habilité
systématiquement ou de manière beaucoup
plus régulière au moins sur des
orientations prises devant l'assemblée
nationale qu'il y avait eu des votes de
l'assemblée nationale il y aura eu un
débat politique avec une opposition avec
une majorité et peut-être les décisions
auraient été similaires mais peut-être
pas mais en tout cas les françaises et
les français auraient pu voir la
décision se prendre aurait pu voir de
justification
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation où
on a eu 116 bill mort du co vide 7
millions de personnes contaminées en
france et où personne ne comprend
comment les décisions ont été prises
aujourd'hui encore les décisions se
prennent au conseil de défense sous le
sceau du secret sans savoir qu'ils
participent qui propose sans que des
contre arguments ne puissent être
exposés et à chaque fois que le
gouvernement se rend devant le parlement
c'est pour présenter ce qu'il a déjà
décidé avant même que ce soit votée donc
il n'y a pas de débat on ne peut pas
gérer une crise de cette ampleur sans
qu'il y ait de justification politique
sans qu'il y ait de départ et c'est pour
ça que ça interroge également sur la
gestion globale de notre système
politique et sur la nécessité de
remettre les choses à plat pour ça que
nous arrive jean luc mélenchon propose
qu'en 2022 ce soit le cas avec une
sixième république dernière question
jean philippe dugoin clément on se
souvient qu'en 2018 un emmanuel lacroix
avait réitéré son sa promesse de
supprimer la cour de justice de la
république un françois hollande avait
fait d'ailleurs d'eux mêmes promesses
non tenues en tout cas pour l'instant
peau pour les deux pourquoi elles sont
si compliqués de la supprimer et est-ce
que surtout il fallait le faire si
d'ordinaire chez réalisé que les
promesses n'engagent que ceux qui les
reçoivent aujourd'hui ils s'en mordent
les doigts aux plaisanteries m mise à
part
une grosse bien reçu
il ya un vrai sujet aujourd'hui et je
rebondis sur ce que disent et d'autres
intervenants il ya aujourd'hui un défaut
de responsabilité politique il n'y a pas
de responsables politiques qui va l'être
délit ou qui va reconnaître cette plante
et où avoir échoué et cette absence de
responsabilité politique la façon très
centralisé pour ne pas dire plus dont a
été géré la crise ça amène aussi un
certain nombre de citoyens parce qu'il
pense qu'il n'y aura pas de réponse
politique de réponse administratifs ils
soient apportées à se tourner vers la
recherche d'une réponse pénale ce qui
pour le coup je pense à des effets
induits qui peuvent être pires qu'autre
chose pour notre capacité future à
répondre mais ça doit aussi nous
interroger sur le fait que l'exercice du
pouvoir hypercentralisé on a aujourd'hui
il n'est plus adapté à la france du
xxième siècle il est plus adapté au mode
de fonctionnement on a aujourd'hui et
que le fait d'être politique c'est aussi
être responsable c'est être responsable
politiquement autres joueront les plus
on risque de glisser vers des
responsabilités pénales qui sont pour le
coup extrêmement
dangereuse pour l'action aureliano comme
le mot de la fin effectivement sur cette
suppression de
vous rappeler qu'en général la
proposition c'est que on supprime la
cour de justice de la république pour ne
pas avoir de justice à deux vitesses
c'est donc pas supprimer la cour de
justice de la république pour faire en
sorte que le gouvernement soit aux deux
autres mc on disait il voulait offert
d'aider justiciable comme les autres de
ses ministres simplement on supprime la
cour de judo et demi qu'on a fait des
justiciables comme les autres et donc
ils sont responsables devant la justice
ordinaire ce qui n'empêche pas qu'il n'y
aurait pas pu y avoir de mise en examen
puisque la justice de droit commun peut
tout à fait mettre en examen quelques
uns pour non assistance à personne en
danger or ça ne résout pas le problème
voire peut-être par rapport à ce qui a
été fait c'est d'or ça banalise le le
recours à la justice voilà je pense que
le plus important à la sortie de cette
crise c'est effectivement d'affirmer
qu'on a besoin à un retour de la
démocratie qu'on a besoin de se défaire
de cette sorte d' autoritarisme de cette
centralisation des pouvoirs dans les
mains du président de la république qui
ressemble plus à un monarque républicain
car un président de la république et
qu'il faut un recours à la
responsabilité politique nous propose
des solutions pour ça la 6ème république
le référendum révocatoire le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne qui ont été
portés eux aussi parler gilet jaune donc
voilà il est temps que les choses
changent il est temps d'amener des
propositions et il est temps aussi que
emmanuel macro et son gouvernement
s'interroge sur ce qu'ils ont fait et
assument leurs responsabilités
politiquement merci en tout cas à tous
les deux d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt français d'avoir accepté ce
face-à-face merci messieurs et c'est la
fin de cette émission ne manquez pas ce
soir 22h30 dans la grande interview
dalil medvedev le tennisman russe qui a
remporté son premier titre du grand
chelem en battant le numéro un mondial
le serbe novak djokovic le leader de la
nouvelle génération dorée du tennis
mondial dit tout à grégory petitjean
quant à nous on se retrouve demain à 20
heures pour une nouvelle émission
non et
[Musique]
en suisse un fonctionnement politique
très particulier
elle permet à ses citoyens de se
prononcer sur les lois temps proposé et
même de les faire retirer éventuellement
en suisse il ya deux outils le premier
quidam est d'attaquer les lois l'autre
instrument c'est l'initiative populaire
qui permet d'introduire un nouvel
article de la constitution fut de même
que un sujet aride en votation signifie
qu' un problème ce qui oblige les les
partenaires politiques à se remettre
autour de la table bastien il pourrait
pas y avoir des dérives populistes vrai
que leurs proches ne risque de la voir
les votations sur des sujets dits
populiste est réelle mais je pense
malgré tout que le meilleur moyen pour
lutter contre le populisme c'est
précisément d'en discuter et de trancher
le résultat d'un voeu peut réserver bien
des surprises pour mieux comprendre où
vous aideront à y voir clair
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk sommes au bord
de la volga le plus long fleuve d'europe
nous sommes chez vox harry
allons faire connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour à ba et là on
est
alors je suis arrivé en 2005 pour
étudier dernière fois en profiter en
2011 demande pas un petit peu non ah oui
et c'est tous les fromages tous les
soucis sont toutes les
les croissants la pâtisserie traits de
caractère des russes qui te plaît
l'amitié les gens les gens très stylée
les français ne savent pas je ne pensais
jamais de ma vie faire la plonge ans et
demi vous pouvez me souhaiter bon
courage
[Musique]
à très bientôt